it's a major wake-up call for the left a
Georgia Democrat tearing into her
party's slide into extreme liberal
policies after she switched sides to be
a republican she said in a tweet quote I
didn't leave the Republican the Democrat
Party the Democrat Party left me when it
embraced left-wing radicalism
lawlessness and put the interest of
illegal aliens over the interest of
Americans I have nothing to apologize
for
Georgia's state representative Maisha
Maynor is now the first black Republican
woman to ever serve in the Georgia
General Assembly and get this she
represents one of the bluest parts of
the state the newly minted Republican
delivering a message from Black
Americans voting for Democrats the
Democrat Party has not been focusing on
black Americans for quite a while now
we cannot say that we care about people
in marginalized communities if we want
to keep them suppressed and oppressed
um one of the things that bothered me
the most is when I would ask them why
are we doing this why is it okay for
kids to not be able to read their
response to me was we've got to give
them hope in response I would say since
when is a lie hope if you really care
about black people the black people that
are elected need to do something about
the issues for the black people that
they represent
pretty incredible Dana I I know that she
was on your show this morning and you
know here you have a woman who is going
against her party and she's doing so at
Great risk be a great political risk too
because of the uh the area that she's
from in terms of re-election right her
District but President Biden won the
district she represents by 89 so there's
an election coming up next year in that
district and we'll see what she's able
to do what I love about it is that she
doesn't care if she's not re-elected
she'd like to win again because she's
trying to be persuasive and to get
people to change their minds uh the
first two things she said that were
important to me when I heard her this
morning is she said education and crime
so we've been talking a lot about that
especially since the national report
card came back two weeks ago with the
abysmal results and I think that what
she's trying to explain to people and I
would suggest when she's talking about
them put some real numbers to this
because if you are unable to read and
write and and do math at a grade level
in eighth grade your chances of going to
jail
not graduating high school not being
able to get a job are so high for I'll
just give you a couple
in unemployment people without a high
school diploma at 10 percent compared to
four percent with people that do have a
high school diploma we're not even
talking College here and so we have
school districts entire school just I
think in LA county they cannot get 8th
graders to a position where they can
actually read and write so what does
that mean you get pressure on the uh the
system for benefits but also jails so if
you want to reduce jails one of the best
ways to do it is to focus on K-12 I
think that she will
is so well spoken
that if she decides to have more of a
prominent position in the Republican
party she will do that oftentimes people
who switch parties are even more
strongly convicted than the people who
have been there for a long time and I
thought she was really gracious this
morning
I thought she was great too I saw her
this morning
um you know one of the things that she
said Harold was that she was crucified
she said as I said earlier that the
Democrat Party abandoned her here's a
woman who put
um she refused to put unions in front of
children and education she refused to
put communities uh you know against the
defund the police I mean she has some
very strong feelings I mean do you see
yourself in that same party where you
have those same feelings of putting
Community ahead of unions making sure
the communities are safe as opposed to
defunding police I won't I won't pray
first of all I I salute this this young
woman for uh for doing what I think
every public servant should do you you
serve your constituents when you serve
your conscious and that may require you
to leave your party at times to vote
against your party at times she should
be no more penalized for supporting uh
uh ways thinking more creatively and
innovatively about how we educate kids
that have been behind
um then a republican who votes for
common sense gun safety laws you should
be allowed to vote for what you want to
vote for and not have your party uh
trash you she took the step an
extraordinary step to say you know what
I no longer want to be a Democrat voters
in the district will have an opportunity
to weigh in here but I don't like litmus
test judge I think no party should apply
litmus testing only litmus says you
should apply is what voters in that
District want and she's standing up for
students for kids in her district for
families who want safer neighborhoods
and if you read that whole statement she
obviously has a point of difference with
Democrats on immigration as well so I
salute her and salute her for standing
up for what she believes in for serving
her constituents her conscious and we'll
see where where this takes her in terms
of an election you know Jesse a recent
poll found that 72 percent of Americans
uh voters believe that improving K-12
education is a top priority and should
be a top priority for State lawmakers I
mean you know we see Glenn young can
kind of around the the edges once in a
while is that like a set up for Glenn
young and to jump into this race
I don't see room for junkan right now he
has a future now is not that
Republicans need to reach out to
blacksmoor they need to reach out to
Hispanics more and Asians more would you
like to hear the Jesse Waters black
Outreach plan
go for it
number one the Republican party has to
remind everyone that the Republican
Party fought to free the slaves that
tells the truth about the history of
this country and it puts the Democrats
in a very awkward position I would
encourage black Americans to leave the
cities these cities
the air is not clean the quarters are
cramped there's crime
get some fresh air you can go to Alabama
Georgia Tennessee Colorado you could get
cheap land you get a beautiful house and
what comes with that I'll tell you what
comes with that better health you're
walking you're outside it's cleaner you
know there's no violence around there
and better schools are out there you're
not in these Inner City Public Schools
you also have access to guns so they
won't let you have a gun in Philly they
won't let you have a gun in New York
it's almost impossible to do that so you
can exercise your second amendment
and then you hit the school's obviously
school choice
but lean into Christ because black
Americans are very religious they don't
talk about it the same way the
Republican Party talks about it it's a
little bit of a cultural difference but
the Republicans should really lean into
that and then lastly focus on marriage
and homeownership combining marriage
with homeownership
that creates wealth and that those two
concepts
are the main concepts for wealth
creation in this country that is the
Jesse Waters black Outreach plan and I
encourage everybody different from the
White House
Jesse you know Greg
the Northwest evaluation Association
found that the average student needs
about you know four months four and a
half months of additional time for Math
and another four for uh reading how do
we resolve this problem I mean people
can move from party to party but the
kids are still suffering first I the
interesting thing here is you notice
when anybody's ever leaving something
whether it's political or it's uh
cultural or media driven or whatever
it's always from the left to the right
it's people that said this has gone too
far no one ever goes hey I'm going to go
over there because they got great ideas
although the media wants you to believe
that our culture is more left than it is
it's not it's not and what you're seeing
is people that are finally saying enough
to your question uh what what to do I
don't think you can do anything that
Jesse uh uh so eloquently said so
eloquently said he really is our leading
African-American historian
um but um you know under the one percent
rule uh that he has under one percent
black I believe point one percent point
one percent but but the thing is a few
years ago we said all these major ills
in our society in general come from one
major problem and it's K through 12. so
you can't talk about marriage and you
can't talk about kids and you can't talk
about drugs and you can't talk about
racial conflict or crime unwed pregnancy
you you can't talk about that stuff
until you fix that one thing at the top
you fix education at the start and you
end up with an amazing Rebirth of
society that affects all of these but
that also threatens the status quo and
the rent Seekers who rely on a broken
system to make money I mean the fact is
if Society if we live in a society where
all these problems go away you don't
need the five we go away too but we
would want that to happen and exchange
for utopian society you speak for
yourself I know exactly but we allow for
choice in everything but here and I
think it's because it is so scary if you
change the design of this system you no
longer create the product that does what
you say uh the desired outcome is is
even though somebody might be a criminal
or outside the status quo whatever
they're still a dependent on government
uh do you think of a a young black kid
leaving a high school that Prides itself
on math and English and responsibility
and self-discipline and manners would
spend one minute copying a tick tock
video that you know asks you to risk
your life or participate in Smash and
grab no they've got better values they
got they got self-confidence they don't
need that stuff and it goes and so I
think we have to to tackle that the
concept
of the of being a teacher has always
been selflessness it's called a vocation
right that's why we adored them when we
were kids we loved our teachers they
were like the closest thing outside your
family who you loved and you trusted and
then what happened was teachers unions
put the needs what you said put the
needs of the teacher over the needs of
the student so the vocation kind of
changed and then you erased this
otherworldly Aura Aura of the teacher
and it's replaced by this whiny gross uh
grievance Machinery that the unions
represent and I think that's where it's
got to change Choice get these get these
kids away from these unions get these
teachers out of these engines back to
the days when the kid when the teachers
were like something revered but we had
to do a better job but but have we lost
these kids probably which is fine with
me I'm getting old
I don't go out at all I don't need to
see the kids you know I stay inside well
armed okay I went on Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now